Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Fue un festín sin igual en Egipto.
El dios guerrero Set
y su esposa la diosa Neftis
decoraron un salón de forma
extravagante para la ocasión,
y colocaron en el centro
un bello cofre de madera.
Invitaron a todos los dioses ilustres,
a decenas de deidades menores
y a monarcas extranjeros.
Pero ninguno causó tanto revuelo
como el hermano mayor
de Set y Neftis, Osiris,
el dios que gobernaba Egipto
y traía prosperidad a todo el territorio.
Set propuso un juego:
quien cupiera perfectamente en el cofre
se lo quedaría como regalo.
Uno tras otro los invitados intentaron
entrar al cofre, pero ninguno cabía.
Finalmente llegó el turno de Osiris.
En cuanto se recostó,
todos vieron que cabía perfectamente:
otra victoria para el dios
a quien nada le salía mal.
Entonces Set cerró de golpe la tapa,
encerró a Osiris dentro
y arrojó el cofre al Nilo.
El cofre era un sarcófago.
Set lo había construido especialmente
para atrapar a su hermano
y el objetivo del festín
era usarlo como señuelo.
Set llevaba tiempo sintiendo celos
del exitoso reino de su hermano,
y pretendía reemplazarlo
como gobernante de todo Egipto.
El Nilo condujo el cofre hacia el mar,
donde flotó a la deriva por varios días
hasta encallar cerca
de las costas de Biblos,
donde un gran cedro creció a su alrededor.
La esencia del dios
dio al árbol un aura divina,
y cuando el rey de Biblos lo notó
ordenó que talaran el árbol
y lo llevasen al palacio.
Él no lo sabía,
pero el árbol aún contenía el cofre
con el dios más poderoso de Egipto.
La victoria de Set parecía absoluta,
pero no había tenido en cuenta
a sus hermanas.
Neftis, la esposa de Set,
era también su hermana;
y su otra hermana, la diosa Isis,
estaba casada con su hermano Osiris.
Isis estaba decidida a encontrar a Osiris
y convenció a Neftis
de ayudarla a espaldas de Set.
Las dos hermanas adoptaron la forma
de halcones y viajaron por todo Egipto.
Unos niños que habían visto
el cofre flotando cerca
les señalaron el palacio de Biblos.
Isis cambió de disfraz
y se dirigió al palacio.
La reina estuvo tan encantada
con el disfraz de la diosa
que le confió el cuidado
de su bebé, el príncipe.
Isis decidió conceder al niño
la inmortalidad al bañarlo en llamas.
Cuando la reina observó
aterrorizada esta escena,
Isis se mostró como deidad
y exigió que le entregaran el árbol.
Tras extraer el cofre del árbol,
lo abrió pero Osiris ya estaba muerto.
Con tristeza, llevó el cuerpo a Egipto
y lo ocultó en un pantano,
mientras ella buscaba
los medios para resucitarlo.
Pero entonces Set encontró
el cuerpo y lo cortó en pedazos
que desperdigó por todo Egipto.
Isis había perdido a Osiris
por segunda vez, pero no desistió.
Buscó por todo el territorio
en una balsa de papiro.
Una por una, localizó todas las partes
del cuerpo desmembrado de su esposo,
dispersas por las provincias de Egipto.
Hizo un funeral para cada una de ellas.
Finalmente, consiguió reunir
todas las partes excepto una:
su pene, que había sido devorado
por un pez del Nilo.
Con lo que tenía, Isis reconstruyó
y revivió a su marido.
Pero sin su pene,
Osiris estaba incompleto.
No podía permanecer entre los vivos,
ni retomar su antigua posición
como gobernante de Egipto.
Ahora gobernaría Duat,
el reino de los muertos.
Aunque antes de irse, concibió
un hijo que continuaría su legado
y, llegado el día, lo vengaría.